I've got a cute little mathematical fact
for you would you might like every
positive integer can be written as the
sum of three palindrome numbers and I've
learned that cute little mathematical
fact from this paper a palindrome number
is something we have talked about before
it's a number that's the same forwards
and backwards as an example something
like 120 1 or 937 thousand seven hundred
and thirty-nine would be a palindrome
number they go forwards and backwards
this paper states that any positive
integer can be written as the sum of
three palindrome numbers and just to
show you this doing example so I
actually set brady up for this we did an
example in advance I asked you for a
significant number I was hoping for your
bank details or something like that but
you gave me a date and actually look I
was quite surprised that you gave me
this date I like it I like it a lot you
gave me this date which was 3004 1777 I
had to ask you what that date was and
you Tommy it was Gail's birthday coughs
one of our great mathematicians I'm
finally converting you Brady you
wouldn't have said that seven years ago
so let's let's do this we're gonna write
this number we just treat it as a number
we're gonna write it as the sum of three
palindrome numbers just to give you the
idea to zero one zero zero one zero two
plus the next number will be nine three
zero five zero three nine and the third
number will be six three six six three
six each one of those is a palindrome
number forwards and backwards they are
the same and if you add them up you get
our target number here at the top the
thing is the reason I didn't do this
live is because in this paper it
explains how to do it which involves 40
pages of algorithms and special cases so
if you want to learn how to do this
great go for it but you're going to have
to memorize 40 pay
of special algorithms so I didn't do
that what I did do is I used a website
that was made by a friend of mine so
Christian Larson perfect made a website
so that you can try this out for
yourself and you can enter any number
you want and it's going to give you the
three palindrome numbers as described by
the algorithms in this paper let's do an
example here I'm going to enter the
first few digits of pi 3 1 4 1 5 9 2 the
website will run these algorithms for us
so that I can write it out for us
so we've got 2 2 0 0 0 2 2 + 9 2 6 6 - 9
+ and hit our third number 1 4 + 9 for
one palindrome numbers three of them and
if you add them up you get our target
number the paper guarantees that you can
always do this you can do this in any
base as well this is not just base 10 so
the paper actually proved it for any
base in fact the paper proved it for any
base greater than 5 and the small base
is 2 3 & 4 that was done by someone else
in a different paper but it's kind of
unsatisfying when I'm saying these
algorithms exist and I'm not even
showing you them so I thought I would
show you one of them I'll do an example
with the algorithm as explained in the
paper just do the example I've just done
here with the first few digits of pi and
we'll see how it works out according to
the paper ok that's our target so that's
that that's that n let's call it n as
our number we're going to create three
palindrome numbers I'm going to call
them x y&z if you use the paper each
number is categorized into a type so
you're gonna have to find out what type
of number this is so you go through the
paper you look it up and if you do that
it's called a type III number so this is
Type A 3 and that means you have a 1 in
the second place it means the two ends
are different and it means the first
digit is greater than 2
so with those conditions that's called a
type III number and then if you look at
the paper it tells you how to start off
the three palindrome numbers and it
tells you that the first number is going
to start with a two it's gonna be one
less the first digit will be one less
than the first digit of your target your
second palindrome number is going to
start with a nine here in the second
column and that's always going to be
true with in this type of number a three
and the third palindrome number it's
going to start with a one and now this
come from the difference between the two
ends of the target number so we're
starting with a 1 now you have to use
the paper and look up which algorithm to
use because there's whole bunch of
algorithms to use this actually
algorithm 1 so there to use algorithm 1
to complete these palindrome numbers for
free you automatically get the last
digits because they're pound roams so if
it starts with a 2 it ends with a 2 here
if it starts with a 9 ends with a 9
starts with a 1 here ends with a 1 here
and does this add up it looks like it
does I've got 1 plus 9 plus 2 would give
me a 2 here and a carry or what actually
I might write that down I'll put a carry
of 1 I'll have a career Oh also if you
use this algorithm tells you to put in
the first number right in the middle
which if I again get the middle of this
so it must be there it puts you tells
you to put a 0 right there in the middle
it's a bit like a Sudoku yeah if you
look up the algorithms in the paper the
reading mind-bending all right what's
going on now they're doing this they're
doing that because they're explaining
every step in really a particular
mathematical language especially because
they're trying to do it so that you can
do it for any base as well but this what
I'm doing it's kind of like a Sudoku
that's kind of the gist of it so we've
got our gap to fill in the second column
I want a 1 up there let's just fill it
with a 2 then I would have 9 plus 2
would give me 11 but be a 1 there there
would be a carrier 1 and that's good
news because that means that column that
first column adds up nicely and for that
second column we don't want to carry
because then it won't work let's put a 0
here for the carry is there anything
else we can discover well automatically
you have a - over there which puts a -
over there as well
now at this point I think it gets a
little bit difficult I think for this
digit here the second digit of the
second pound Rome I think we're going to
have a choice for this now the algorithm
tells you what to put in so I'll just
follow the algorithm I think you could
perhaps have a choice but the algorithm
tells you to put a 2 in that position if
you get a 2 over there you automatically
get a 2 over here so maybe we can
complete this column now with one a9
I've got a caviar one I've got a 2 and a
2 so I must need a 4 here and the next
carrier would be a zero down here I
believe automatically you get the four
over there for this column let's see I
wanna four I've got most of it depends
what the carry number is down here I'm
going to assume and this is what the
paper tells you to do it tells you to
assume it's a 1 and if it's if it's not
a 1 you're going to fix it later
that means if I add that column up I'll
need a 0 in that position
so that adds up to 4 and automatically
you get a 0 in that position we've
completed the first palindrome now
what's missing well we've got this
missing digit here the paper does tell
you to put in a carry of 1 if you don't
know so we say that's a carry of 1 we
want this to add up well we've got 5 1 1
so we're going to have to put in a 6
there and then automatically a 6 there
and that completes the second palindrome
number and now we just want got one last
digit to fill in so we want to fill in
this last column so we need a 5 I've got
a 6 I've got a cow a of 0 so that must
be a 9 right there that fills in the
last palindrome number and you should
double-check that it works out but in
this case we've been lucky it does work
out if you add up these numbers you get
our target number these were a couple of
assumptions that we made if they were
wrong we can fix it at this step and the
paper does tell you how to fix the
number if you need to make an
just meant but we have been lucky here
that completes it and that is an example
of the kind of algorithms you would have
to memorize if you want to do every
possible number I've memorized one which
I've just done there hi everyone we just
like to say how thanks to brilliant for
supporting this episode brilliant is a
website that I completely love I love
just browsing it they've got lots of
stuff on there stuff that's free you can
look at any time I particularly enjoy
their problem of the week which come at
different levels of hardness I'd
recommend having a look at that one but
they've also got these great courses and
lessons and quizzes which is beautifully
designed really elegant but also
designed very cleverly to make you
smarter
that's what brilliants all about us not
just about doing tests and seeing what
your scores are it's about changing the
way you think changing the way you
attack problems getting you to think a
little bit more outside the box and if
you enjoyed the video you just watched
the number Theory course in particular
might be one for you go and have a look
at them at brilliant org slash
numberphile as I said there's loads of
stuff on the site that's free but if you
go to brilliant org slash numberphile
you can actually sign up to their
premium service for 20% off and that
gives you access to everything all the
good stuff
our thanks to brilliant for supporting
this episode people who wrote the paper
said that this was a kind of a
mathematical folklore thing so it was
something that they had heard of before
and obviously if you play around with it
you can always do it it's always true
but it hadn't been proven to be true
before this and apparently took them all
these algorithms to prove every possible
case